okay time once again for the movie
retrospective this time around we are
doing not only one of my favorite
anthology movies but also another one
their good friend Rob so yes such a DVD
of it I had never seen this movie yes
Tom had never seen it even though this
came out in 1983 this is Twilight Zone
the movie I saw this a million times
when I was a kid I mean this was on
cable all the [ __ ] time I think like
we taped it on VHS I must have seen it
oh my god I must have seen at least 100
times an excellent movie and every time
it came on I would watch it again it's
an excellent movie every story on it is
good that came from the old the old
Twilight Zone series know that I grew up
with and they slightly changed they
reboot it so so the endings on each one
of them are a little bit different that
way you don't really know what's gonna
happen yeah but well actually not know I
think kick-the-can the endings about the
same I think the ending of that was the
same yet now three of these stories were
remakes of some original Twilight Zone
episodes the first one was the one with
Vic Morrow which we'll get into that in
a little bit because that's kind of a
famous thing because of the horrible
thing that happened on set but I think
that was the only original story the
other ones were remakes from the
original series now this was done by
Steven Spielberg and John Landis they
were the producers on it
Spielberg actually directed the
kick-the-can segment John Landis did the
first segment and then Joe Dante did the
third one which was like the kid that
could wish people into the cornfield but
it was like an updating of that and
George Miller of Mad Max Fame did the
last one which was the one on with the
man on the wing a plane which originally
the original one had William Shatner in
it huh yeah this one has Chumley yeah
that one ended about the same two I
think I think it did also we just showed
more in the in this one yeah that's
pretty good
there's also like some little Easter
eggs because the narrator cuz obviously
by the time they made this Rod Serling
was dead so the narrator this is
actually burgess meredith who was
actually in a whole bunch of twilight
zone
episodes back in the day also you know
the kid like in the original it's a good
life the kid that would wish everybody
into the cornfield in the old black and
white one bill moo me he was actually
had a cameo in that segment like I think
he was one of the he was one of the guys
in the diner like where anthony's
playing a tempest like on the video game
and he's gonna kick the kids ass or
something like that so they put like
people from the original show in here
too but like in little cameo roles which
i thought was kind of cool now one thing
that i always loved about this i swear
to god i can't hear and every time i see
this movie
that [ __ ] Creedence Clearwater
Revival song is like stuck in my head
for like weeks and weeks afterward
midnight special um and that's how you
always knew that this [ __ ] movie was
coming on which is like the strain the
first strains of like midnight special
coming on and then you got [ __ ] dan
Aykroyd and Albert Brooks in a car like
sing it and I used to like even though
it takes a while for that to build up
because they just like go on this big
long thing where they like they're
playing a TV theme songs game and [ __ ]
cuz they're on a road trip or whatever
and it's just like there's something
that I really really like about that
opening prologue just with the two of
them in the [ __ ] car and then listen
to the Creedence clear one of them
they're like singing along for like five
minutes or whatever then the tape breaks
and then they're like hey you want to
play TV theme songs and then they're
like [ __ ] you know the [ __ ] with them
like singing along with the song it's
like you know what all this other kind
of crap when he was doing like the
National Geographic theme and putting
words and me was with it for me what
stood out in the movie was Scatman
Crothers I thought I thought seeing him
you know I mean I didn't I didn't expect
him to be in it but seeing him in the
movie [ __ ] was like oh yeah it's
pretty cool cuz it he's old-school you
know musician going alway back he's
playing speakeasies in the 30s but he
does a really good job kind of uh he
then another the the one that with the
one with the the gremlin on the on the
wing yeah I want to think that one I
think that's the best story in the in
the compilation the best rendition of it
yeah the one with the kid who can wish
people out in the corn
I liked that version of the story in
this one but it wasn't as good as the
original and in terms of okay well the
special effects are a lot better yeah
a lot better but they redeems the kid in
the end in this one and no you shouldn't
redeem the kid the kid yeah because I
think yeah the kid was like I don't even
remember what happened at the beginning
of the error at the end of the um and
they're the originals of the kid one
yeah he did didn't yeah I haven't seen
that dick you want yeah the kid you want
is likely and everyone else remained
under his power and that's that's
basically how it ended
yeah I guess they wanted more of a
character arc yeah I guess or for some
reason they wanted to redeem the kid
which that that is kind of like clipping
the nuts off that story the reason why
that story was so scary is how hopeless
the situation was yeah it's like what
the [ __ ] could you do if you were like
under the sway of like the little kid
they could do anything yeah he had made
his childish into a parallel universe
nothing else existed just his town yeah
that's pretty weird you know Danny had
God he had godlike powers yeah but yeah
it was it was it was a good movie yeah
it's like I I feel like the it for me
it's like all of the stories are good
it's weird because I haven't seen this
like I saw a million times one over the
kid but then I hadn't seen it for
probably 20 25 years and when we saw it
again I could have sworn there was five
stories but there's only four I guess I
maybe I was thinking a Creepshow because
that has five stories but um I feel like
that all the stories are good but the
last two are my favorite like the ones
with the one with Anthony and the man on
the way in the plane yeah and the first
three was just kind of generic throwaway
story up now the first one I was the
only one that wasn't a remake of of
something else
now what ended up happening with because
we got to go into this and Robbie even
like sent me a message just like that
could be a whole episode on its own so
the first episode which is you know
about this cranky [ __ ] who sounds
like my grandpa um or did cuz my
grandpa's dead but um and he kind of
gets his comeuppance because he's just
like jus this
and word that and spearchucker this and
you know what I mean so he kind of gets
set back in time to like Nazi Germany
and then he gets sent to Vietnam he gets
all this other stuff and you know so you
would think that he would like learn a
lesson and stuff well what ended up
happening with this now while they were
on set they didn't shoot this in Vietnam
obviously but while they were shooting
it apparently John Landis who directed
this episode and look I love John Landis
I love an American Werewolf in London
stuff like that but this is some [ __ ]
up [ __ ] right here so they were shooting
like really late at night and there were
these two kids like two child actors
because there was supposed to be a
sequence in this episode where you know
the cranky [ __ ] like saves these two
kids like from a from a bomb or from
getting shot or something like that
which was kind of like a redemption for
him right so they were shooting that
scene in the middle of the night and
they had these two little kids and John
Landis apparently said that they'd hired
these two kids under the table because
under California labor law you can't
have like two little kids working this
late at night like without a tutor or
anything like that so he was
circumventing those laws because he
wanted this scene shots so that ffunny
was doing and what ended up happening
was that so they weren't being super
careful apparently the one of the guys
who was doing like the pyrotechnics cuz
it was supposed to be like a big
explosion and all this other [ __ ] he
wasn't really watching what he was doing
either and then like he set off the
pyrotechnics either too early or he set
off two of them together and they were
supposed to be separate and it caused a
helicopter to crash the helicopter
beheaded Vic Mauro the guy who the actor
who plays the cranky [ __ ] in this
segment and beheaded one of the kids and
crushed the other kid under a helicopter
now to save a few bucks to save a few
bucks now famously not only did this
cause a huge rift between Steven
Spielberg and John Landis
I mean Steven Spielberg ended his
friendship with John Landis
over this because he said you know
nothing is worth dying for like saving a
couple bucks or like making a movie and
that's like he was like horrified by how
John Landis had covered it but this also
resulted rightfully so in a whole bunch
of lawsuits now that John Landis as well
as a few of the other people who were
working on the crude that had been you
know instrumental in like hiring these
kids and everything were actually
brought up on manslaughter charges
however they were they in the end it was
found to be just like an accident and
even though they were kind of liable for
hiring the kids and everything like that
it wasn't you know the fact that they'd
hired these kids illegally that didn't
directly lead to the helicopter crashing
that cause even though the kids
shouldn't have been there because they
shouldn't have been working at that time
of night because it's that's against the
law I wouldn't have stopped the
helicopter from crash enough right and
that and it still might have killed the
actor but it's like the fact that the
two kids were there too it's like you
know that kind of made everything so
they'd so he did actually get off with
it but a lot of people are still still
really don't like John Landis because of
this because they feel like he was
directly responsible for the deaths of
those two kids at least has been you
know what I mean because you know
because they were well apparently a
judge agreed because no one was found
liable they said look it was just an
accident yes the two kids shouldn't have
been there and he was held responsible
for that and he did come forward and say
that he felt responsible for it and
everything like that but like I said
it's you know that's kind of a thing so
that it's weird because of the original
twilight zone pretty much every story
was like a morality tale yeah but not
that first one but the first one was
kind of not because I mean it happens at
the end of it it's basically he's just
taken off in a cattle car like
presumably to you know to a
concentration camp and he doesn't I
guess he learns a lesson like oh [ __ ] I
shouldn't have been such a dick to
people but the reason that it's
truncated like that is because there was
supposed to be a Redemption scene where
he saves these two kids from a bombing
in Vietnam and then that was supposed to
be like he learned his lesson or
whatever but because because they didn't
there was some footage and apparently
this is horrible and I'm sure it's
probably on YouTube please don't search
for it but apparently there is footage
of the accident and Vic Mauro and the
kid getting beheaded maybe they shot it
from three different angles so the
footage is out there somewhere they had
a bunch of footage of him and the kids
and the whole like lead up to this
sequence but after that happened he
didn't want to use any of the footage of
the kids that they had already shot you
know understandably so so they had to
like cut out that whole sequence which
is why that first one seems like it
ended kind of I don't know if it ended
abruptly but it just seemed like there
should have been more like more to it
like he should have really kind of
realized yeah it's I didn't like the
first one because like you said it
didn't it the story didn't really end
that's why I was not that's right I just
call it kind of like a throwaway story I
I remembered that somebody got killed
but I didn't realized the the witch
story was yeah anyway yeah that wasn't
really in the spirit of Twilight Zone
Twilight Zone would present a problem
and then they would resolve it yeah well
like I said it was supposed to it was
supposed to it's just Twilight Zone
episodes were usually some kind of
morality tale yeah and that first one
was it the other ones were yeah and the
other ones were the ones that were
remakes from yeah although I think the
one about the kid at the cornfield the
kid in the cornfield one what's the name
of that episode you remember it's a good
life it's a good life that's right it's
a good life
the original telling of that tale was
ominous because it the resolution was
that there was no hope yeah it was a
[ __ ] black pill and talking about and
that's what gave that story strength to
change it the way that they did the
ending that was a very positive and
upbeat ending for that you know that's
exactly the opposite of the original
tale which day you know you could do
that yeah I mean I'm sure they didn't
want to make it exactly the same yeah
it's an artistic decision but I liked it
when Esther it was a damn piano and you
should you know you should know too that
Joe Dante directed the third segment and
he was more known for his horror
comedies like gremlins and stuff like
that yeah so you know and like stuff
that was heavy
special effects you know I I feel like I
don't know I feel like that one might be
my favorite just edging it out a little
bit just because I always really liked
the atmosphere of it I liked the inside
there's there's no cornfield there's no
nothing like that it's just this house
it's by itself and you know the inside
of the house is all this weird like
lighting and it's like this kid and it's
like when I first saw it I was probably
only 11 years old I don't think I had
seen the original Twilight Zone I knew
that there was one but I didn't think I
don't think I'd seen it and so I didn't
know you know when Helen the teacher
when she brings Anthony back to this big
mansion and all his family members are
acting super weird and those liked all
like all the weird food like the
hamburger with the peanut butter on it
and like you know they're all like
really nervous around him and I didn't
know why that was so I was like really
really intrigued and then like he takes
her upstairs and they start going
through all her [ __ ] like taking all her
cigarettes and [ __ ] like that
and I suppose I specifically really
loved the the one shot and it's just
like a throwaway shot but the shot where
he's talking about his sister oh she was
in an accident and then they pulled back
and then she doesn't have a [ __ ]
mouth
it's like oh man I loved that I used to
creep me out so much as a kid but since
I hadn't seen the original I don't think
the ending of it like the more
redemptive ending bothered me as much
just because I loved the suspense of it
of not knowing why everybody in this
house was acting so weird and why they
all seemed to be afraid of him and then
you know and and to like the [ __ ]
special effects where he's you know he's
telling his uncle uncle Walt to like
pull a rabbit out of a hat and you can
just tell by his face he's like oh [ __ ]
man like he doesn't want to put as they
ended there so you know it's gonna come
out and then like this book and they
have all this crazy like cartoony like
Tasmanian Devil kind of [ __ ] it's great
it looks great still yeah it does I mean
all the Crito the practical effects of
like that looked fantastic um the
original there's two different versions
of its a good life
there's a longer version that wasn't
allowed to be shown on television or
later on they cut it out
based on a book I think are on a short
story is it yeah if you guys haven't
seen it's a good life that it's probably
on I think Netflix and that look says
most of the old Twilight does right and
I don't remember which version of it's a
good life is on there but one I've seen
both versions but I remember they
stopped playing the original version on
television after a while because they
cut out a scene at where I think he
turned somebody into like a like a like
a Chaka and puts them inside the
television and they're running from a
big old dinosaur and that I think you
know the guy gets eaten by the dinosaur
and then the dinosaur falls off the
cliff something something like that
so they kind of omage that in the new
one yeah because he puts Ethel into a
cartoon and then gets eaten by a dragon
cut that out
they eventually cut that out of the
later on TV version I don't care I
thought it was too upsetting
yeah but if they they may have well in
the 70s at least they did that because I
remember in the 70s it was it vanished
in the late 70s early 80s it started to
advantage but I remembered it being in
there and I remember because like I said
I might not have even seen that version
because I didn't see the original
toilets and it's a good life and we've
been at later a Chaka yeah you see you
came up with that turned him into Chaka
and then then all of a sudden there I
always say yet turn that [ __ ]
ain't wit cha a Chaka is a caveman or
somebody who looks like whoa because we
lost yeah well that was his name his
name is Chad Amos chose a little hairy
eight boy well it just it amused me
because when I was watching the thing I
just yeah I was amused by the fact that
that little eight band's name was Chaka
but then I thought well Chaka could just
be a generic term I like like a
chocolate it's not just you that in the
army we used to call people choc every
now and then every now and then call
somebody yeah if they had a lot of body
hair there's just no we got a slightly
buck-toothed you name I call Chuck he
was pretty buddy buck - yeah buck -
gap-toothed he was bit gap-toothed
yeah that's right more than buck - holy
[ __ ] that makes me want to watch
remember how like we watched the [ __ ]
Land of the Lost like some of the old
episodes the other day yeah I can't
believe how [ __ ] cheesy that [ __ ] is
also like I said I can
believe the [ __ ] sexual tension but
we had quote-unquote brother and sister
ki no really brother and sister but
holidays getting rid who she was wanted
to jump on that deck holy crap how old
was she 13 14 maybe maybe hormones man
you could tell young girls to not hold
it back she was like I notice it when I
was a kid obviously but it's like I was
watching it now no I business she's
totally the will she just can't even
walk past him with that beat you could
see the magnetic force you know you see
the estrogen coming off I use a magnetic
force go watch so watch YouTube you'll
see what we're talking about I couldn't
believe it she's definitely reacting to
that guy and he's trying to play it off
yeah he's trying to ignore it she might
have been older than she looked but um I
don't think she was all that I'm
supposed to be 12 yeah but I think she
was a little baby
I think she might have 15 6 15 16 yeah
which that's not too crazy I don't know
how old he was
she was now gonna have to go he was
trying to fight it you could see the
gravitational [ __ ] yeah
field it was so so funny we were just
like all because I was like let's
partially to lost i'ma war since I was a
little kid and like what we both said
the same thing at the same time we both
like talked I mean she might you might
as well have seen her like little eyes
go like she swooned every time she
[ __ ] was saw the dude she's [ __ ]
swooned and [ __ ] what you call cousin
will or something like that or I thought
was her brother I think it was a cousin
but there wasn't supposed to be the
attention there
well yeah like I said there's been
automata better supposed to be related I
thought they were brother and sister but
I might be remembering that wrong yeah I
think you remember wrong I think what
Holly was I had to go back and watch it
again
it was Marshall the dad was Marshall the
dad of the uncle or the uncle I think I
thought I think she was calling him
uncle will I had to go back and look at
[ __ ] another thing when I forgot is how
quickly that series progressed yeah it
was like all of a sudden
stacks and then it all happened like
eight episodes and they're like well
[ __ ] I thought I was watching that for
years until you know instead of that I
think happened you know I had to go back
and watch it again and they were the
episodes are very short and very simple
yeah they're like 15 minute and they are
entertaining but they're very very
simple yeah very very simple I thought I
thought they were funny but yeah so you
know they're flying around in the pylons
and [ __ ] and I thought that took forever
before they were I did to you I ever I
remember them like farting around with
Chuck and the dinosaur for like a long
time yeah big strawberries and
everything when you're a little kid two
episodes which is seems like we ever
seemed like forever
I guess though yeah but yeah so yeah so
that we talked about the first one we
talked about the third one now the
second one is kicked the can this one
was directed by Steven Spielberg and it
is easily the most Spielberg II of all
of the all of the stories it's not as
creepy it's not as horror oriented like
I guess but it's more like heartwarming
yeah but I kind of like that though
because it kind of balanced out the
other stuff cuz the first one was like
kind of really unpleasant and then the
third one is kind of more like a
sinister cartoon and then the fourth one
is just like kind of a scary monster
thing so what they have like a nice
magical you know
a magical heartwarming well a lot of it
a lot of the twilights years a lot of
the Twilight Zone episodes were heart
warm they were yeah now that I'm
thinking about it wasn't all scary I
don't think I remember because it says
according to Wikipedia like kick-the-can
was also based on one of the original
Twilight zones although I can't I don't
remember seeing a memory you saw it yep
so it was okay well I'm a close that was
pretty close yeah I mean you can't [ __ ]
man you can't lose the scatman I don't
worry I did was like the coolest I don't
remember the Scatman Crothers a
traveling rejuvenator I don't remember
that character in the original I just
remember a kid that could kick the can
and make everybody younger no it was an
old guy who was convinced that he could
do it oh I did see that and then he
started to act young and he became young
and his friends saw him saw that happen
and then he
went in and he tried to explain to
everybody else so what how can towards
the end they all did get younger and I
think that's how it ended they didn't
they didn't go back to their normal age
so I guess it was like slightly
different than the original story which
is it was because this one is basically
you know Scatman Crothers and he plays
mr. bloom and apparently he's like he
just goes from rest home to rest home
you know getting these old farts to play
kick-the-can yeah and I don't think that
character was in the original I don't
think so either another Jim maybe that's
why I didn't make the connection yeah
but yeah so he's getting to play
kick-the-can and because he's like got
magic powers for whatever reason they
actually do get younger yeah um but my
original was two guys and one of them I
think was just daring the other one he
says do you realize maybe you know this
remember we used to play kick-the-can
and [ __ ] I guess that's some [ __ ] you
did back in the [ __ ] 1890 yeah it was
just like poof and stick you know well
this was like okay so this this came out
in 1983 so like the people that were in
the restroom of this were like you know
would be old as well they'd be dead now
maybe the originals came out of 50 so
they were talking about what the 20s no
not even not even it would have been way
too late 18-hundreds kicking a can well
even in this one like in the 1983
version like the two women that were
talking about how their favorite game
was like jacks yeah and I was like wow
that was a long time I remember Jackson
she was supposed to be the one woman
that said that was supposed to be 78 in
1970 in 1983 when I was a little kid
little girls play with Jack's and I was
in the same as I did to you and I was
really about the ball and pick up the
jack yeah I did have some so maybe that
wasn't it but it just seemed like a
weird it seemed like the weird first
thing to like go to where as if somebody
said to me like what was your favorite
yeah I had Jack's and I was a kid but if
somebody said to me what was your
favorite game when you were a kid I
probably would have said like [ __ ] oh
no play-doh or mystery mansion or
something like that or Legos imagine
imagine a millennials don't even know
what Jack's are yeah it's like I feel
like that's I haven't even seen them
like in a store not that I've looked but
but yeah so right now I think like you
said in the original story did they all
stay kids I think they did
when they did it I think it panned back
and then you know with you to have you
know [ __ ] what's-his-name Roger Lewis
sitting there [ __ ] smoking his ass
off in that damn suit you know you know
kid you know Jude you know age is
nothing more than you know say some deep
[ __ ] you know in the twilight zone
yeah I really did way all became kids
and they were in a damn out in the
backyard of the damn convalescent I'll
run around playing you know as kids I
think it's a whole convalescent home
turned into kids yeah it was like
contagious when one when one of them
learned and then the last one was a guy
who kind of refused to become a kid
again yeah they did that in this one
tale it was just there was one because
there's always one there was always one
grouchy [ __ ] that didn't become turned
back I don't think they turned back to
old TC and this one though they they
played his kids for like a little while
other what's weird because I hadn't seen
this movie in a long time and it's like
I thought that they were kids longer
it's like it was basically just one
night and then they fired it around as
kids like for a little while and then
all of a sudden they were just like wait
this sucks
they're like we don't have any parents
and it's like our life sucked anyway we
don't want to go back to school it's
just like let's be old again I had they
had a bunch of never about kids there's
another one about some kids that would
dive down into a swimming pool their
parents were getting divorced and they
were kind of like real rich [ __ ]
California modern couple from the early
60s to the late 50s and they're getting
a divorced and and the little kids are
unhappy about it and they could dive
down into the swimming pool and they
would go into another dimension and come
up out into a lake whether it be like
Huckleberry Finn there and country kids
I remember that one remember that one I
remember and eventually they said [ __ ]
it they stayed over there
that's how I remembered it I don't know
if I'd want to stay in Huckleberry Finn
world yeah it was and I'd have to be a
pretty [ __ ] cold dementia for maeda
wanted today there it was a lot better
than what they had true even though that
what they had was like living in like
Beverly Hills
yeah of the time you know there's like
no thanks was yeah there and bare feet
and catch frogs and painful yeah and
stuff yeah but I think they stayed young
forever cuz you know oh well okay that
might be forget forever and like a
Huckleberry Finn oh no that would I have
to think about that one it was the
values of the time
because I was trying to think about like
because when I was rewatching kicked the
can just recently and I'm sitting there
going one I really like the message of
it like I said Scatman Crothers he can
do no wrong I just love that [ __ ]
dude he was just like the coolest dude
ever
so it's and he can make anything sound
awesome you know what I mean so I really
like the message of I mean he was the
perfect person to play this role because
he comes off as like he was clearly like
an older guy but man's brother was born
old
he was yeah even like young pictures of
him and look at old he was young still
yeah yeah he was born old but because of
that maybe you know even though he's
obviously an older guy in this he had he
still has that childlike wonderment type
of thing like cuz some old people have
that and so he really had that so I
think he really sold this role so where
he just like comes along and you know
gets him all to be young again for a
little while so I really liked that
message where it's just like and you
know you had the one like like I said
the grouchy old fart that's just like I
don't want to be a young [ __ ] that [ __ ]
he was just kind of like that and and
then ironically like after all the other
you know kids like God they decided they
just wanted to be old again but the one
mr. Agee he decided cuz he was like
Peter Pan and [ __ ] and he decided he was
gonna stay young and you know and so the
cranky old guy was like oh no I want to
go and they're like too late now
[ __ ] you should have gone before
but I like that whole message where it's
just like you know even though you're
like oldest [ __ ] you can still you know
you can still act like a young person or
you can still like have a youthful kind
of thing about you now let's talk about
before we end the review let's talk
about the last segment
like I said directed by George [ __ ]
Miller got it yeah guy from Mad Max um
and you can tell because this one's like
action-packed yeah so like I said this
is probably the closest to be to the
original they don't think they changed
all that much
have you just showed more yeah because I
think the original with the shat and I
have to say that in this one the the
the way the plane or the monster looks a
lot looks like one good haul in town
lightning onto the thing and [ __ ]
yeah it was like all slimy don't have
yeah and I have to say I mean John
Lithgow in this he plays a fantastic
crazy person
yeah although his eyes were just bugging
out of his [ __ ] head and [ __ ] like
that if you haven't seen you if you
haven't seen the original William
Shatner see that one - that was a shut
the shad [ __ ] you know the shadow
[ __ ] made his mark was he like
throwing himself all around like there's
someone on the wing of the plane yeah
another thing in the plan you need
somebody that's like gonna overact in
this yeah I mean you don't I mean you
just need it for this type of thing
because jad didn't over every over and
he was that was the acting of that way
his acting style was the acting style of
the day you know I guess but he had kind
of a Johnson on it
yeah people remembered him then he was
successful trail he got work he did yeah
you got work got work even you know even
after uh even after Star Trek you know
you did kingdom of the spiders and [ __ ]
like that you know we like those movies
I love King Thomas King that's like one
of my guilty pleasures that in like Orca
yeah like all this [ __ ] 70s like
nature disaster yeah there was no decent
[ __ ] you know shabath show up in the
[ __ ] made-for-tv movie you know he
was he was a name he was in the devil
people forget that and his face melted
off yeah people forget that you know he
had a lot of work outside of he did Star
Trek he was in a touch that he's just
Noah's gonna be known for Star Trek that
changed yeah I mean you know that was
his iconic role yeah huge role you know
what happened to Leonard Nimoy - well I
mean Leonard Nimoy had some other [ __ ]
going on - cuz he had like in search of
and other stuff but yeah you know but
yes so this last segment like I said
probably I don't know it depends on the
day I feel like the third one is maybe
my favorite or this one is maybe my
favorite I just loved John Lithgow in
this and I can like really relate to
this hard because I mean as soon as this
one starts John let's go I was like in
the [ __ ] the tiny airplane bathroom
and he's just like wigging the [ __ ]
like his hair sticking out his eyes are
bugging out and I said hey me on an
airplane I hate flying too so I can get
it oh you had a little girl character
which I liked that with her that little
girl was funny I remember delightful and
I don't like child actors generally but
she was just well she was so sarcastic
and like so deadpan and but like not in
it over-the-top kind of way you know
what I mean deep bells aren't here here
she don't fall I'm not gonna fall I'm
gonna fall out and she's like you know
chastising you what do you why don't you
do that like a normal person but he
don't like me and she was like funny in
the funniest [ __ ] and I one thing I like
about this too is that in a way like you
know there's a man on the wing of the
plane we know there's a man on the way
in the plane and at the end of this
thing you know yes there really wasn't
man on the way of the plane because they
find like claw marks and everything like
that but the fact that when they're in
the sky and no one believes him and
which in a way you can see why you
wouldn't because he looks like a lunatic
and he's acting like a lunatic but then
there's this really great like they did
a really great thing where everything
like all the shots seemed like really
weird like almost like vaguely fish-eyed
so it's almost like you're seeing
everything from his point of view like
everybody's like peeking over the top of
their seat like looking at him so
everything looks a little bit surreal
you know what I mean and I think that
really like kind of adds to the
creepiness of it or something like that
is like not only just because of the
monster but it's like then you have like
all these like people like poking like
the little girl and she has the [ __ ]
ventriloquist dummy like a grocer thing
like and oh oh no smoking you know what
I mean so she's like [ __ ] so everyone's
like kind of chastising him and like
jumping on him and like yelling at him
and stuff because they think he's a
nutcase because of course nobody sees
the monster but him yeah we're calling
it a monster it's a gremlin it's a
gremlin and in the original it was just
a man in a choco suit yeah yes more
chocolates more chocolate shop full of
chacas damn gorilla suit I don't think
this is just the [ __ ] baby it looks a
real dump man it's terrible like Bigfoot
on the way the points look even though
you would think I thought and you would
even think in the original one did they
want it to be a
yes a gremlin is like Vina from World
War one or World War two or whatever
that was what they said about you know
when a German thing
yeah when [ __ ] went wrong with the
planes oh the gremlin you know and I
made the evil spirits inside of the
machine yeah that caused problems so
when I think of gremlin maybe it's just
because of the Joe Dante movie when I
think of gremlin I don't think of Chaka
or Bigfoot I think of life as slimy
looking gremlin like the one that's in
this one I think of a grandma and I
think of the grandmas that they in the
old Looney Tunes it's a little bitty man
with wings coming out of side of his
head and a wing on top of his head the
wing okay that's where a gremlin looked
a little gray suit yeah if you can't see
the visual effect kind of feel sorry
wings coming out the side of each hand a
wing coming up off the top yeah I see it
like when when people say the word
grandmum like I said it's hard to say
because I've you know grew up watching
[ __ ] the movie gremlins but I just
feel like the word gremlin
sounds more like a little green thing
with cloth not a furry thing that looks
like a person that's what they had in
central casting and that's really what
do we have that can look like a kind of
like a monster well we have a gorilla
suit
it's a chalk ass yeah there's a truck
yeah yeah there's a new t-shirt shotgun
on the wing of the play this version of
a grandma looks kind of like a UH like
like to think from Pumpkinhead yeah it's
like yeah I like this one like it looks
like a person but it looks like real
pale white yeah it looks like a
reptilian was like reptilian or
fish-like or looking at it Lovecraft II
microscope
like Pumpkinhead yeah and he's got like
kind of things like almost like
dreadlocks or something like that so it
looks like that yeah yet here he did
yeah so it looks a lot cooler um and
like you said he looks like he has a lot
more powers because like when John
Lithgow like you know his eyes bugging
out the window and he sees the thing the
thing is sitting there like throwing
[ __ ] into the engine and like blowing
the [ __ ] call the lightning bolt down
into the end yeah so it's you know and
it could fly too because they showed
like when it was flying away like
because the plane was gonna land it was
gonna crash the plane presumably but I
guess because I
he did it because he got seen or he
didn't have enough time or something
yeah he got too close to the runway he
didn't have time I guess to tear the
plane apart yeah so John wig I was like
hanging out that because of course he
shoots out the yes and so that was a
little bit different it clearly shows
that the protagonist saves the air he
did and that it wasn't a hallucination
there was damage there and thus at
version it was not clear whether or not
is it ambiguous wasn't good enough know
that it wasn't clear that him shooting
that it saved the save the airplane but
it did leave yeah and then later when it
panned back it showed the engine and
there was a piece of it [ __ ] pulled
back what was going in there from if I
remember correctly yeah in the original
so something was out there on the wing
trying to damage the yeah engine but I
did like the end of this and like I said
I can't remember if this is how the shot
one ended but at the end of this one he
carried amount of strength they carried
him out and he said I saved everybody or
something like that so he did like it
say that he had saved it but everyone
thought he was crazy because they put
him in a straitjacket before they saw it
was just crazy like mumbling to himself
and fighting this train so they don't
they weren't sure yeah
or he wasn't sure I guess I also have to
say I really always liked the way they
brought back the prologue or the
wraparound and they incorporated it into
the last story because they put John
Lithgow in the ambulance and I guess
they're taking over the psychiatric ward
or whatever and then you hear Dan
Ackroyd's voice and he turns around and
he's like hey I want to see something
really scary you know to be like he's
driving the ambulance which is like a
callback to the beginning which I
thought was really I really liked the
way they book ended it like that it's
also like a shout-out to Creek show that
too you know
yeah which um almost show when did that
come out that came out 83 no 82 okay so
that was like the year before this okay
yeah all right so because for a second I
was thinking oh that came in after this
big night great show was the first of
these and I think Twilight Zone was and
was a response to creep show when it
that's why I think so yeah where I
remembered it yes yeah
it was kind of like a big boom and like
anthologies I never came out with Erie
oh yeah with cousin Erie and you never
came up with eerie and creepy mr. Schad
those two key members there's like these
used to trip me out when I was a kid man
yeah creepy thought hey they wouldn't
allow those today I don't think somebody
needs to get on that they wouldn't allow
those to do they go what is it shutter
could do it they did a [ __ ] Creepshow
now talk about the comment of those
comic books
oh that caused a lot of problems they
were trying to ban him for kids cuz they
would have a lot of adult content and
things but we could buy him anyway yeah
you know there was I don't think it was
cursing at him but there was pretty much
nudity in it lots of [ __ ] weird
violence cannibalism yes they were
really gory
yeah and they had a lot of the stories
were good though those are really good
never creeped you out when you were a
kid put it down do you have to think
about it yeah you go back into it look
at the guests cuz you were it's like you
were looking at something you weren't
supposed to be looking at yeah yeah like
don't let him see this yeah cuz you'll
take this away from me
we did okay though even though we saw
all that Chaplin yeah but yeah I feel
like the 80s were kind of like there was
a lot of really good horror anthology as
they came out there's this one a creep
show and [ __ ] cat's eye which we
should probably do one of these days
they were even let you know tales from
the dark side although I think that was
1990 we should probably what was the
other one that I was thinking of there
was like I said I think I've mentioned
this on the show before but I think
there was one that was called nightmare
or nightmares and all I remember I think
it was three or four stories and all I
remember is that the first one had
Emilio Estevez in it and he was playing
a video game called the Bishop of battle
and it kind of like sucked you into the
video game or something's kind of like a
Tron thing I haven't seen it in a really
long time I'm gonna have to look that
[ __ ] movie up again because I haven't
seen it in a really I remember seeing it
like a whole bunch of times but because
I loved [ __ ] anthology movies still
do so I saw pretty much everyone that
they put out some of them are better
than others but that was one that kind
of stuck but only the first story stuck
with me firstly not the Tron man I got
to see the original tribe that that was
a [ __ ] masterpiece from what I
remember yeah I remember really
and just visually I remember it being
real visually impressive yeah because it
was like CG the very first computer
graphics one of the first one of the
first never taking place in a computer
world they made a sequel to it it wasn't
bad but it's hard to capture the time
you know I mean well that's true of any
right it's hard to capture what movie
that came out is because it's always
like a time capsule of the time they
came out and if you're gonna remake it
it's like I'm not saying they can't
remake things but it's never gonna be
exactly the same because it's not the
same you're never gonna be contacts
around it isn't the same never gonna be
able to remake Disney's the black hole
and get that same tone of what it was
like to see it in the year that it came
out ya know it's just not gonna happen I
was just reading about some people like
that had seen that in the theater today
talking about him it scared him it was
scary for kids it was one of the darker
he was very funny movies very murder it
was very much a vampire movie in outer
space really yeah with [ __ ] Count
Dracula and his damn bucket spaceship
with all his zombies and [ __ ] Dracula
with his own [ __ ] demonic robot and
it's a some people bag on it you could
see wires I didn't notice any wires in
our [ __ ] blu-ray version of it no I
didn't either
no it wasn't actually a ton of blu-ray
it's just it's just an HDD I think DVD
and we saw an updated version rent we
rented an updated version of it I didn't
remember seeing any wires
yeah I think they digitally removed him
yeah probably yeah you what you would
think it's easy to do easy to do now um
but yeah so if you were into anthology
movies and somehow did not see Twilight
Zone in the movie from 1983 it's not the
best horror anthology the 80s and like I
said some you know the first or the
second segment is not really horror but
if you're a fan of like the original
Twilight Zone series and you like that
kind of tone you like Spielberg [ __ ] you
like John Landis is [ __ ] then you
definitely need to see this do I
definitely think the last two stories
are the best ones but I really like the
whole movie there's something really
comforting about it like I said I love
that [ __ ] opening prologue with the
two of them in the car like singing all
the theme songs and stuff it's like I've
seen it so many times that I haven't
[ __ ] memorized and it just like still
cracks me up every time so yeah this is
this is one of the
comforting movies of my youth that I saw
like a million times so thank you very
much
rob for sending me yeah thanks a DVD of
this because this is something I will
probably up there with Creepshow many
many times I see is up there with creeks
show yeah it not is not quite as horror
base it's more more thriller fantasies
yeah in terms of quality and
entertainment about like about like
creep show yeah but I really do love
toilet down the movie and like I said we
should definitely do more anthologies we
have so many movies on the [ __ ] list
that we have to do though yeah did we do
that one I don't think we did we need to
do a review of that one I think maybe we
can do that around home I thought we did
it we I think we did too like cuz I
bought it remember I bought it for like
$3 or something like that but yeah so
Twilight Zone the movie